hey guys it's inka welcome back to
another episode of trendy versus
traditional where i'll be doing trendy
interpretations of your favorite
classics today representing the
traditional side will be my friend vic
how you guys doing i'm vic and i'm ready
to go
today we'll be doing oh
today we'll be making
pizza
i was a delivery driver it's a fun time
in my life always nice to be in a pizza
shop all right so that means you're
professional you can handle this i've
watched the guys do their thing i
wouldn't consider myself a professional
per se but i think i could definitely
hold my own in this challenge damn okay
well a little nervous but
i'm gonna start us off today i'm gonna
go first all right well good luck thank
you that was so confident he has so much
confidence let's get this bread
let's get this bread you know for today
our trendy pizza is actually going to be
the pizza cone it's basically the same
as your average pizza slice except it's
shaped into a cone the cone is the crust
and then the choppings go inside the
reason why i chose this particular
recipe is definitely something that i
thought was super simple being i work at
buzzfeed i looked one up on tasty and it
just so happened to be a really simple
recipe that you'd be able to use at home
just a little bit nervous because i know
inga always does her thing in the
kitchen so it's uh it's gonna be a tough
competition but i love pizza i think i
got a little bit of experience i've
dabbled with it before so i'm pretty
confident that i'm gonna be able to give
her a run for her money i bought some
cool gadgets they look like little
traffic cones we're going to shape the
dough using these little guys but first
things first we're going to start off by
making the dough because that is the
most time consuming process there's this
recipe that i've been doing to make
bread just normal bread where it's
called a no-need dough which means you
don't need to knead you don't need
all you have to do is combine some
ingredients set it aside and you'll have
this beautiful airy dough first thing we
want to do is get our yeast mixture
ready i'm going to throw in my sugar
give me a second there because i forgot
which ones would throw in the yeast
there
just got to let that rest do this thing
for about 10 minutes and you'll start to
notice it's going to start bubbling up i
got some warm water here active dry
yeast give it a little mixy mix instant
bread smell once that's combined i'm
going to add in some bread flour first
thing i'm just going to throw in a
little bit of salt to season the flour
don't like anything bland throw in some
of this yeast mixture in there olive oil
i'm throwing in for some flavor slowly
you're just gonna start working around
the volcano crater that you've made here
i'm a big fan of making fresh made pasta
so this is a little bit similar you know
how normally people when they eat pizza
they eat like the parts with the
toppings and then they leave the crust
i'm the opposite i eat the crust
and then i leave the top and sometimes
don't judge me i've always loved the way
this looks it's no time i'm just going
to set a quick timer to make sure that
i'm kneading it for long enough
i left my phone over there home
thank you sir set timer for 10 minutes
okay looks rough around the edges it's
not really smooth and that's okay all
you got to do now is seal it and then
wait for 12 to 18 hours so what i like
to do is press out and kind of fold back
in
turn it around push fold back in this is
really fun i gotta say i always enjoy
kneading it's a nice uh process very zen
a lot of times what i'll do is i'll just
put my headphones in jam out to some
music maybe a podcast something like
that and then just let the time fly so
this has been fermenting for 17 hours
and this is what it looks like
oh man it smells like yeast the gluten
has developed there's a lot of bubbles
it's going to be airy now we just got to
make sure we don't destroy all the air
that we have
so what i'm going to do is try to make a
beautiful little ball here and then what
we're looking for really is uh to see if
it bounces back so let's try that out oh
beautiful looks all that bounce
it is coming the dough is coming down
beautiful so let's get this wrapped and
then
i need some ceramic
it looks like venom or like the upside
down
just come down alrighty alrighty alright
so this is pretty much done i'm gonna go
ahead and set this aside and then when
we come back we'll be ready to make some
pizza
okay
see how soft it is it's super sticky
just gonna
divvy it up
everybody needs some personal space i'm
just going to add some oil on top
gotta wrap it up
now we're just gonna wait for two hours
and then we're gonna be ready to roll it
out while we're waiting on our pizza
dough to rise we're gonna get going in
our sauce i love garlic so
i don't mind there being a bunch put the
knife down give it a smash and then that
allows the skin to come off super simply
that was the worst example jesus onion
choked on my saliva
hit it with a cross
boom oil in here grater here
then shallots and our onions
all right and then i'm just gonna sizzle
these down until they get a little warm
throwing the tomatoes in first boom i'm
gonna go ahead and add in our tomato
paste fire roasted tomatoes some salt
some red pepper flakes that like a
little bit of a kick
oregano crushed chili peppers some
pepper some basil
on the money oh
look at that
it's definitely doubled in size at least
right onto my board
beautiful look how that's looking that's
awesome feels like it's a little bit
more springy a nice looking little ball
there so we can portion it out check it
out
see how it's kind of like springing back
into place by itself we are going to try
to roll this out just using my hands i'm
just pressing into it my fingers since i
rolled it so nicely i have a nice
circular shape we're not gonna keep it
circular shape we're actually gonna use
this cut out to cut out around this
shape we're gonna cut it i am going to
wrap it like this around so and
boom
[Music]
another way of doing this wrap it around
like this
just make sure it's all covered tada
these are now ready to go into the oven
they just need to bake like this for a
little bit around five to six minutes
then i'm probably gonna take the molds
out and let it bake for one to two
minutes more just to give it some color
and make sure the insides are cooked and
then we can come back and fill it up
with toppings it doesn't really take too
much sauce that's one thing that i was
kind of surprised about i just see the
guys all the time in the shop is give it
a little spiral fill in those little
spaces i have my cones
they are actually
cones just
do a little thing like that now the fun
part where we get to throw all the stuff
on top i'm gonna start here with my
fresh mozzarella this is always awesome
because you could tear into it and make
sure that i have full cheese coverage
we're gonna do a lot of layers so we're
gonna start with the mozzarella cheese
squish it down add a bit of that amazing
sauce you kind of want to smear it
around the sides a little bit a little
shredded cheese i'm going to fill in
these gaps with a bit of basil in here
fresh muzz now for my favorite part add
on the pepperonis i like to throw it
down the middle in the line first i like
it to be beautiful and symmetrical
fill in the gaps on the sides i really
like prosciutto add a little bit more
cheese okay i'm going to go all the way
because i love pepperoni add some more
sauce again love that little extra
flavor that it gives us there the
saltiness deliciousness more cheese
another piece of ham some more sauce and
top it off with some mutts and then boom
boom i'm ready to go ahead and pop this
bad boy into the oven i just need to go
melt it a little bit gotta make sure the
cheese is ooey and gooey and then we're
ready for the final reveal
[Music]
wow
those are super cool this is a classic
new york style pizza when the onions
made me cry i said don't worry about it
because inga's gonna be crying later i
may or may not have to eat those words
along with the slice of pizza
it is time for our judge to come in and
today we have a super super super
special guest
not not not chris but we have chris's
wife and both of them have a pizza
tattoo and they love pizza and there is
no better person to come
than her
and the pizza bling sweet
rested pizza
[Music]
should we do the flop test
okay okay
that was nerve-wracking
what do we think i like that look i like
that look delicious thank you cheese
supreme i think we just stopped there
right
oh my god it's it smells like pizza i'm
scared
oh you hear that crisp the crunch is
amazing oh my god tastes so good
i wasn't expecting this expecting it to
be
oh no
i like eating with both of my hands the
crust is really freaking good too
but you're amazing as well sounds like
it's gonna be a tough decision oh
no i feel like i'm sweating more now
okay okay three two
one
oh
no
thank you do you think chris would like
these i know he would pick that looks
like we brought in the wrong judge today
we each have
one vote a w for everyone yes
yes
congrats
it was an awesome awesome awesome trial
i'm very happy little pizza cheers there
you weren't playing with this sauce and
the crispiness i feel like i ordered
pizza outside thank you vic for joining
me and thank you for having me thank you
guys for watching i hope you guys enjoy
this episode as always let us know what
other food item you want to see next and
we'll make it happen see y'all next time
[Music]
[Music]
you